was die demonstrationen hier angeht und
die frage ob das idioten sind 17.000
will sondern relation setzen das ist das
dominierende thema seit monaten das ist
eine demonstration zu der seit wochen
aufgerufen wurde da sind 17.000 menschen
viel aber es sind nicht so viele wie zum
beispiel bei den anteil bei demos wo ja
mal eben 200.000 auf der straße hat dass
da eigentlich in ordnung dass die
menschen keine masken getragen haben bei
den und valrhona die und teil des länder
über die die vergangenen demonstration
blätter zum beispiel ist bei keiner
demonstration gerade in ordnung dass
masken nicht getragen werden dass
abstand ich ein geld wird das erwarte
ich von allen demonstrationen
niemand von uns in der spd sagt das
demonstrationsrecht muss eingeschränkt
werden aber wir erwarten dass man
vernünftig demonstriert und das erwarte
ich auch auf diesen demonstrationen und
dann sage ich ihnen da sind leute dabei
die meinen sie könnten freiheit
erkämpfen in dem journalisten angreifen
da sind menschen dabei die mine freiheit
erkämpfen zu können in dem sie
polizisten angreifen
das halte ich für ein idiotisches
verhalten da sind leute mit dabei mit
reis kriegs fahren mit hakenkreuz
tattoos neben solche leute stellt man
sich nicht alle die sich an mich wenden
die fragen haben die diskutieren wollen
als bundestagsabgeordneter kriegen eine
antwort mit denen diskutiere ich habe
ganz viele debatten im wahlkreis aber
wenn man auf solche demonstration geht
und sich einreiht zu reichs bürgern zu
verschwörungstheoretikern zu leuten die
hakenkreuz tätowiert haben dann muss man
genau aufpassen wer links und rechts
neben ihm steht und dann trinkt nur noch
verantwortung dass man sich in solche
demonstration einläuft